guys this is only going to take a couple
of seconds you've seen the images the
heart-wrenching images of those kids in
Yemen who are starving we must do
something about it click the link below
and donate
[Music]
now how are you guys doing Mariam Fran
Sarah is a 42-year-old French journalist
who's done some good works for um the
pales Palestine cause in fact she's
recently come on in Zan's SM J had a
video supporting her uh the da boy
zishan is supporting her because of her
good works for Palestine and also she I
remember watching some of the things
that she used to do on something called
Big questions which is a program that
used to come every Sunday in the UK and
she was one of the main protagonists in
fact advocating the pro-islamic position
you know clarifying some of the
misconceptions about Islam very
articulate very good and um
unfortunately I don't know what's
happened but she's embroiled herself in
what I'm going to be calling the sexual
name calling Scandal and I don't
understand where this came from one of
my friends sent me a lecture of hers
where she delivered and she delineated
her positionality if you want to call it
that both theologically and
ideologically I want to leave you um
with one clip and then come back and
respond to in kind defensive posturing
about the great gains Islam brought for
women in the 7th Century says nothing
about whether or not it continues to be
a force for good in the advancing of
women's rights today this first clip
here okay she is questioning whether or
not Islam is a force of good in the
modern world now someone may make a
plethora of different excuses for her
and say that she was just doing this
maybe I'm misinterpreting what she means
by Islam maybe she means it in a
civilizational sense maybe she means it
in some other sense okay no problem
let's look at the second clip and high
profile cases of sexual slavery from
India to here in Europe are sadly far
too common but surely the question
shouldn't be whether Islam is uniquely
oppressive towards women but more so why
it isn't providing the liberating
principles which were so critical to the
prophet peace be upon him's early
message moving to textual Islam itself
there are undoubtedly verses and sayings
of the Prophet peace be upon him which
continue to cause concern in their
current understanding the juristic and
exeresis based Heritage is in many ways
deeply patriarchal and at times
undeniably misogynistic so here she is
talking about Hadith now Islam is
comprised as many people know Quran is
and Hadith these are the primary sources
of Islam and she's talking about ISL the
Hadith the prophetic sayings which are
the Hadith and in their Juris Prudential
understanding which is the mainstream
normative traditional understanding and
she's
questioning whether or not they're
misogynistic and she is actually saying
that they are undeniably misogynistic
now once again if I were to go in a
street now and ask people whether or not
they would think that a Muslim could say
this I think that they would say no I
would say if I were to put the words of
Mari and franois sah to people in the
streets they would say this is likely
said or these words are likely said by
some anti-islamic proponent someone may
say okay well maybe she meant that maybe
she meant this let's take a look at the
third clip most Progressive
interpretations continue to argue that
this is merely a symbolic gesture
symbolic symbolic of what we must
question of power relations which give
men the right to treat grown women like
petulent children my feeling generally
about religion is that it ought to
elevate the soul to higher ethical
Plains if we fall back on the all too
easy these are problems found everywhere
the question remains of what exactly
Islam is in is contributing to improving
women's lot rather than adding its own
layer of culturally or religiously
specific justifications for these
injustices so here she's talking about a
verse in the Quran 434 chapter 4:34 and
she's quoting a progressive
interpretation she in her words and
she's rejecting this Progressive
interpretation now my question would be
then if you're rejecting the most
Progressive interpretation of 434 what
interpretation do you accept do you
accept any interpretation because the
the answer this question implicates you
as either a Muslim or non-muslim so if
you say no I don't actually believe in
this verse and say what AM will do said
who was a feminist um who said I had a
conscientious Gap when I looked at 434
she said these are the words she used I
had a conscientious Gap okay if that's
your position then the question is how
is it the case that you still identify
as a Muslim I mean this would be the
question I then ask because Islam is you
believe in every single word of the
Quran you believe in every single
instruction given by the Prophet this is
what Islam is but it gets worse actually
because as I was listening to these kuf
statement and statements of disbelief
and statements of deviance and all those
kind of things and I was feeling sorry
for her and actually feeling a great
deal of disappointment actually there
was something else that I realized that
she was actually making blunders about
the Islamic tradition let's look at the
fourth clip and take a look at what
we're talking about to's teachings
regard pregnant women as models of
meditation because of the recognition of
the Superhuman levels of concentration
and Transcendence required in labor
women are quite literally Al masters of
meditation to be studied and learned
from all I could find in Islamic sources
was some advice about eating
dates it's sad and telling that
pregnancy and child birth and child
rearing are not afford afforded the
preeminence in our Scholastic manuals
that they ought to just viewed
legalistically through the dry prism of
juristic formalities so here she says
that she Compares Islam and and this is
astonishing actually it's actually
outrageously ason astonishing because
she's comparing Islam with taism okay
and she's saying that when you look at
the taist tradition you see that the
pregnant woman for example she's being
described in this way which is she has
superhuman meditative
capabilities and comparing that with
what she found in Islam all she could
find is a few scraps here and there
about woman taking dates when she's
pregnant now this is a ridiculous thing
now to my knowledge she does not have
access to the Arabic language number one
but I will say to you you don't even
need access to the Arabic language there
are hadiths of an eschatological nature
of a spiritual nature for example the
Hadith of very famous one if a pregnant
woman dies giving birth then she dies a
Shah she dies a mat I don't think the
Tais tradition or the Christian
tradition or the Jewish tradition or any
other tradition actually has a Hadith
this explicit and this respecting of the
woman's position as a pregnant woman
exactly the category that you have
spoken about is of all things you could
have mentioned you mentioned a thing
which Islam puts so much stress on and
gives so much to respect to women on and
I could speak for hours about this
actually but it shows with all due
respect your ignorance on the matter so
for example in chapter number 46 of the
Quran where Allah you know Allah
mentions about the
mother that the woman when she's giving
when she's pregnant she's doing so in a
state of uh difficulty and when when
she's giving birth she's doing so in a
diff state of difficulty there is
commemoration there is recognition of
the woman's position as a pregnant woman
okay in the Quran I would argue more
than any other ancient religious text
okay for you to to make a mockery out of
yourself not even the Islamic tradition
by misrepresenting the Islamic tradition
and saying that well all I could find
was a few things here about the dates
and this and that Sor it shows your
ignorance on this topic it does show
your ignorance on this topic but putting
that aside okay okay let's get to the
Scandal and the title of this video what
is the Scandal my friends were sending
me some things yesterday after she uh
blocked me on um on Twitter and I didn't
understand what was going on I mean she
she's now attacking the da guys and then
she blocked me and then she it turns out
this woman has been trying to get my
attention since
2022 and she's been uh you know quote
tweeting me or whatever it is and saying
things let's take a look at the screen
and see what we're talking about here
referring to uh me and
as in Muslim incel Twitter and then on
the other hand we the F boys she
referred to us famously recently Ali has
a video responding to that as F boys
okay I'm not going to use the the
profanity here but she's referring to us
as F boys which if you look at the Urban
Dictionary whatever it is that you have
to look at means a man who's sexually
promiscuous I mean he's going from one
to another casual sex and these kind of
things but an incell is an involuntary
celebrate so am I are we having sex with
sorry because it's a contradiction isn't
it I mean are we having sex with with
all these women or are we involuntary
celebrate I mean but why is it the case
Mariam sorry I'm going to address you
directly now and don't don't get any
ideas but why is it the case that
whenever you mention either myself or
the da sector in general there's some
comment of a sexual nature that happens
what kind of predatorial behavior is
this what kind of harassment is this now
this is an honest question both of these
both of these things here incel is to do
with a person's non-engagement with sex
f booy is someone's over engagement with
sex why is that whenever you mention the
da boys Muhammad hijab or quote to and
that try and get his attention try and
get their attention huh huh why is it
all the time that you're now mentioning
making references to sexual intercourse
of uh you know in the connotation the
subtext of what you're saying what's
going on if I were to ask you a question
and this is the title of this video what
if Andrew Tate had said the same thing
andrate somebody and we're not afraid to
criticize him with I mean I made a video
just last week criticizing the man for
his alliances with uh the right wing
just last week got 300,000
views but he's been lambasted I mean the
mistakes that he's made in the last year
okay of a religious nature he's been
lambasted by the Muslim Community men
and women by the way both both have
lambasted him you've been a Muslim for
20 years as a revert yeah you've been a
Muslim for over 20 years
and you're now making all these mistakes
that we've seen here of a theological
nature
which by the way have not seen any
reprimand of surprisingly surprisingly
surprisingly Annie and now you are
taking a segment a sub segment of Muslim
men and you are generalizing them you
are speaking about them in this
way what if Andrew Tate had said the
same thing about Muslim women let's say
for example for the sake of argument
hijabi influences like substitute
da boys with hijabi influences and let's
make Andrew Tate the one who said the
same statements what kind of outrage
would there
be the answer to this question quite
frankly it shows you the level of mandry
that exists in the Muslim community and
at large and what is mandry it it is the
hatred of men I'm sorry to say this is a
reasonable inference to the best
explanation why is it that when one
makes a mistake and he's been a Muslim
for one year that you have all of this
attack and you've been a Muslim for 20
years and making all these theological
mistakes attacking subsections of Muslim
Society using Colonial narratives huh
using liberal and feministic narratives
which are knowledge Productions of the
West now you're imposing them on us you
want Islam to fit in line with that that
model and you're attacking subsections
why is it that you can say that
unchecked and unaccounted and if we say
anything oh but she's a pro Palestine
activist what do you mean what do you
mean that she's a pro Palestine she can
see what what she wants she she was
lecturing for the dean Institute which
is her ex-husband Adam Dean who used to
be part of quilliam who was colleagues
or connected with Tommy Robinson she was
part of a ecosystem of anti-islamic
propaganda and don't let anyone fool you
with all due respect don't let anyone
fool you just because somebody claims to
be a Muslim like quillian Foundation you
have people like maid naaz now he's
changing for the better maybe I don't
know I'm not going to interrupt the
person when they're doing a good deed if
he's going if he's repenting and he's
going in the right direction good if
he's not then Allah will be the judge of
him but he was part of that and he was
claiming to be a Muslim but at the same
time doing everything anti-islamic
allying and sitting and collaborating
with Tommy Robinson and other far-right
people like Sam Harris if you're part of
that ecosystem now yeah and you're
disseminating this kind of falsehood
theological devience with all due
respect with all due respect it doesn't
matter if you're wherever you're from
whatever country you're from whatever
gender you are if you as a feminist I'm
not even going to judge you by Islam now
I'm going to judge you on feminism if
you as a feminist want equal rights then
prepare to face equal
responsibilities I'm not going to
discriminate just because you're a woman
I'm not going to refrain from refuting
you just because you're a woman that
would be a disrespect to your feministic
sensibilities you will get refuted and
repudiated and humiliated even if it
needs to be done okay if you come out
against any members of our society and
just because you had that card I don't
know if if you still identify as a
Muslim as a Muslim now you can go
further than any white feminist could by
the way a white feminist canot say the
things that you're saying without being
labeled as an islamophobe just to let
you know and you know just because you
had membership of that group at one
point in time and once again I don't
know if you still maintain membership
there that you can go further and in the
same video you're attacking you're ATT
you're
attacking huge Scholars and you can't
even speak you can't even uh pronounce
enunciate the Arabic language properly
and you have the right now you think
because you've got you've had some
Western education that you can go and
attack a whole different tradition with
your Colonial mentality no thanks I
don't think so my
friend but I'm going to end this with a
good note because someone will say well
guys I understand where you're coming
from and you have convinced me I know
many women that be watching this video
I'm going to say that you have convinced
me and yes we do have double standards
yes there's a problem with mandrea and
society and all that kind of thing you
have convinced me
haab but let's be honest haab you have
some staunch opinions as well you're a
bit strict you've been a bit
exclusionary with
women as well in your discourse putting
aside that feministic extreme of mar and
franois Sara the Lawrence of Arabia of
the Modern Age that's coming in and
trying to dis disunite
us yeah putting that person to the side
you still got stor views and your your
discourse is exclusionary what I'm going
to say to you is this I hear what you're
saying and we're here to make this into
a complimentary system men and women
should not this these gender Wars we
want to create a ceasefire and we need
to understand that yes this is a
complimentary system men and women
should come together and not have this
embitterment and this hatred and this
unnecessary resentment towards each
other in the community and instead we're
working together in the community this
is what I am now a proponent of I'll be
honest with you if there was a war
between men and women I take the I take
the side of the women I love way more
women than I do men trust me there's
more way more females that I'd want to
protect than men if there was a war
between men and women I'd take the side
of women putting all that to the side
though I'm saying we have a
complimentary system we have a shared
struggle as a minority we don't want to
marginalize ourselves further by
infighting we do want Unity which is why
and this is going to be Shameless here
but I'm going to do a plug here for the
series the series that's going to come
out and change the world it's called
burning hands and it does tell the story
of Muslim minorities in the west it
tells the story of Muslim minori
struggle against far-right people like
Tommy Robinson who this person was
Loosely connected with we we'll tell the
story of our struggle against all of
these forces young people men and women
yes I know we've gotten some controversy
because of it we do have women in the
show but we can't tell the story about
Muslim people without Muslim women this
show is going to come out on the 22nd of
July on this channel it's going to be
free to watch and it's going to come out
at 7:00 London time I'll leave you with
the trailer
[Music]